a orillas del río Chad el arab se
encuentra basura la capital económica
del sur y de aquí oficialmente la ciudad
tiene 2 millones de habitantes pero el
panorama es cada vez peor año tras año
estos barrios informales se multiplican
en los terrenos baldíos al ritmo de la
afluencia de la población desplazada la
desertificación de los terrenos en los
alrededores obliga a los agricultores a
migrar hacia las ciudades es el caso de
Mohamed de 30 años procedente de un
pueblo al este de basura llegó aquí en
2016 y con los años ya conoce bien todas
las calles estamos en el barrio de
xeneilla el terreno le pertenece al
Estado pero nosotros nos instalamos aquí
y construimos ilegalmente utilizamos
bloques de hormigón y chatarra pero
sufrimos por la falta de Electricidad y
de servicios públicos
según las autoridades por su condición
ilegal estas construcciones no pueden
estar conectadas a las redes de
servicios públicos Entonces los se
encuentran otras soluciones el agua que
usamos para beberla desviamos de la red
pública de la ciudad con estas tuberías
verdes que llevamos hasta las casas
necesitamos electricidad porque nos
conectamos a las principales redes
públicas
hace poco su tío y su familia siguieron
sus pasos y llegaron aquí
juntos construyeron esta casa con lo que
tenían a mano
fallec de 50 años trató de permanecer en
sus tierras pero con la disminución del
nivel del Río chatelará el agua salada
del Golfo Pérsico se filtró y acabó con
sus cultivos
la salinidad del agua destruyó todo
acabó con todo a donde podíamos ir no
podíamos pagar una casa grande entonces
nos instalamos en este barrio informal
ahora los dos hombres dependen de
trabajos diarios muy aleatorios
A veces trabajamos como obreros a veces
no encontramos nada
como somos iletrados no podemos trabajar
en el sector Público con un salario
entre 13 y 17 dólares al día no tienen
mucha esperanza de poder salir de estos
barrios pero su mayor temor es ser
expulsados por las autoridades locales
la gobernación Calcula que más de
350.000 personas viven en los barrios
informales y consideran que son la causa
de los problemas de gestión de los
recursos en la ciudad
alcanzaremos la saturación en las
escuelas habrá demasiada presión sobre
los centros de salud y congestión de
tráfico en las calles cada vez Habrá más
consumo de energía de agua y la red de
evacuación de las aguas usadas se
saturará esto afectará a los servicios
públicos confesando estar algo
desbordada por el flujo de personas la
gobernación asegura estar buscando
soluciones
las familias no pueden acabar en la
calle las indemnizamos con una suma de
dinero o con un terreno si son de la
gobernación si proviene de otro lugar
son enviados de regreso a su provincia
de origen
las autoridades no especifican la suma
pero los habitantes afirman que la
indemnización asciende a 3 millones de
dólares iraquíes menos de dos mil
dólares cuando las casas son derribadas
para dar lugar a otras construcciones
como esta carretera
Todavía vive en el campo pero pasa por
aquí a diario para ir a las obras de
basura la situación lo indigna el
gobierno tiene dinero tiene recursos
tiene petróleo Entonces a dónde va ese
dinero
desde la pandemia el 40% de la población
de la provincia vive por debajo del
umbral de pobreza
hassan trata de conservar sus tierras
para evitar tener que sumarse a los
barrios marginales pero en sus cultivos
ya no crece nada y la ayuda tampoco
llega
el Ministerio de Irrigación debe hacer
mantenimiento y limpieza hasta en los
canales
pero no lo hace
A dónde deberían ir los agricultores
para buscar agua tenemos que cavar pozos
como antes cavar miles de pozos Podría
tener el riesgo de secar las capas
freáticas cuyas reservas se renuevan
poco
otra solución la desalinización la
planta de abu ship inaugurada el año
pasado trata tres mil metros cúbicos de
agua al día y es el orgullo de la
gobernación que ambiciona tener un
proyecto similar en la desembocadura del
chat el arado Este es un proyecto
estratégico porque la solución radical
para preservar las aguas del chat el
árabe dependerá del mar del Golfo que es
estable podremos trabajar en él y
ampliarlo en el futuro
Pero estos proyectos son caros y el agua
será destinada principalmente al uso
doméstico ante la falta de medidas
radicales para disminuir este Éxodo
rural las organizaciones internacionales
previenen sobre las violencias que
podrían surgir en las ciudades bajo
tensión